مصر موضوع شائك يتعلق بقضايا النسب اثاره
مجددا الدكتور علي جمعه عضو هيئه كبار
العلماء بالازهر جمعه شدد على ان تحليل
الدي ان اي ليس دليلا واجبا لاثبات النسب
مؤكدا على الالتزام بقاعده الولد للفراش
وهو ما سنشرحه في حوارنا مع ضيوفنا هذا
اليوم طبعا هو موضوع محل جدل دائم بين
مؤيد ومعارض سواء من رجال دين او حتى من
قانونيين اذ اجازت دار الافتاء اثبات
النسب بالبصمه الوراثيه في حاله تنازع على
مجهول النسب او الاشتباه في المواليد
واطفال الانابيب
كل هذا اظل
في غياب نص في القانون المصري يلزم باجراء
تحليل الذي طبعا الذي يعدى الدين هذا
الخبراء الذي يعدون طبعا دليلا جازما في
حسم هذه القضايا فلا تتم هذه الفحوصات الا
اذا وافق الاب على اجراء هذا الفحص
على كل حال مشاهدينا سالنا الناس في مصر
ما رايك في رفض البعض اعتماد تحليل الدي
ان اي لاثبات النسب دعونا نتابع
[موسيقى]
اي افتح بتطلع لازما بتكون طالعه رسميه من
الازهر يعني ما بتبقاش طالعه من فرد او من
شخص يعني لان في الاخر احنا ما بناخدش
اشخاص يعني كل واحد بيبقى له رايه يتاخد
به او
يرد عليه يعني المشايخ يتكلم عن الدين لكن
التحليل الديني ده الطب الدكاتره هم اللي
يتكلموا في ده ينفع او ما ينفعش كده هو
تجرب واتعمل في قضايا كتير قبل كده واثبات
الناس اللي يقول كده طبعا اصحاب المهن
الطبيه واللي يقول كده طبعا الجهات
الرسميه المتعلقه باصدار الفتاوى في مصر
يبقى خلاص الجثه اللي بتخش وتتحلل يبقى ده
كلام اونطه يبقى مش تحلين مظبوط دوت لازم
يكون فيه
علميه وخلفيه دينيه دول هم الاتنين
انا شايف ان التعليقات كتير قوي رغم ان في
ناس كتير بيحاول ان هو يقولوا العكس كده
ان هو بيكلمهم في اساس ان لو حصل اختلاط
يعني مثلا احنا عندنا مثلا ما فيش تنظيم
مثلا اختلاط احيانا ما بين العلب او انت
مش تدوني على الاسم العلبه والناس
المتبايعين
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من القاهره الدكتور عادل عاشور
استاذ الوراثه الاكلينيكيه بالمركز القومي
للبحوث وكذلك ينضم الينا الدكتور احمد
كريمه استاذ الشريعه الاسلاميه بجامعه
الازهر ليبدا اولا مع هذا الراي الذي تحدث
عنه الشيخ علي جمعه مع الدكتور طبعا لابدا
اولا مع الدكتور احمد كريم الدكتور احمد
يعني هل هي حاله واحده مختصه بما ذكره ام
هي حاله عامه على كل الاسر يجب ان لا ناخذ
حفاظا على هذه الاسره حتى لو كان هناك
اختلاف بين الزوج والزوجه او طعن من قبل
احد الاقارب او غيره
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
قال الله تعالى ذلك ومن يعظم شعائر الله
فانها من تقوى القلوب
بطبيعه الحال في باب اثبات النسب في الفقه
الاسلامي
عندنا نصان نص قراني ونص نبوي النص
القراني قال الله تعالى في سوره الاحزاب
ادعوهم لابائهم فان لم تعلموا اباءهم
فاخوانكم في الدين ومواليكم والنص النبوي
قال النبي محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
الولد للفراش يعني للزوجيه الصحيحه احنا
لا نرفض تحليل دي ان ايه لكن هو قرينه
وليس دليلا فقهيا شرعيا قطعيا لاثبات
النسب لان من المستحيل شرعا ان تلغى ايه
قرانيه او يلغى حديث نبوي ونقول ان العلم
الحديث قال
هذا
الدكتور احمد بس قبل ان تستفي ض يعني
البعض يقول بانه الدين لا يعارض تدخل
العلم وهي اذا كنت تعتبرها قرينه فهي قد
تكون قاطعه لانه هذا تقدم في العلم
لكن لا الغي النص الشرعي ما لغيته لا نلغي
الايه القرانيه ولا الحديث النبوي يعني
تتاكد من نسبه لا لا لا لا ازاي يعني مثلا
في علاقات محرمه اللي هي علاقات الزنا هل
ياتي دي ان ايه ليلحق او يثبت نسب من
الناحيه الفقهيه الشرعيه لا اثبات النسب
انما بالزواج
باركانه وشروطه انما في قضايا الانحراف
وقضايا الزنا وارتكاب الفواحش
ناتي بهذا ونضرب بعرض الحائض الاسر
هذا ممنوع دكتور احمد يعني هو
بانه يعني
كل ربما هذه النصوص اصلا هو المحافظه على
الاسره فاذا كان لا خطر على هذه الاسره
ربما لا ضير في استخدام اصلا تحليل
الديانه انا اسال دكتور عادل عاشور
الحقيقه يعني من الناحيه العلميه هل الدي
ان اي يعتبر دليل قاطع لا شك ولا ريب فيه
في اثبات النسب عم بحكي علميا
تمام
تمام يا فندم يعتبر تحليل تقنيه
دليل كامل بنسبه 100% على اثبات
البنوه
لما انها تحمل بدرجه دقيقه جدا تاصل الى
ميه في الميه في اثبات النسب او الانساب
بالنسبه للاطفال وهي الحقيقه
تقنيه غير مكلفه
والحقيقه التقنيه دي برضو عايزه اخش في
حته تانيه انها بتكون رضع للزوج او للزوجه
او الراجل او المراه اللي بترتكب فاحشه
وعارفه ان ما فيش تحليل هيثبت ارتكابها
للفاحشه دي سوى الرجل او الست وبالتالي
لما انا اعرف ان في تحليل هيثبت ان الطفل
ده ابني او مش ابني اعتقد بالنسبه لي او
بالنسبه
للزوجه او للمراه هتكون راضع لها وده
يحافظ كمان الاسره وبالنسبه كمان للتحليل
الدي ان ايه دون
الحقيقه لازم نتكلم برضو عن
الميراث هنا انت ازاي
هتربي ابن مش ابنك وياخد ميراث سها من من
اخواته طبعا غير شرعيين فالقصه بالعكس انا
التحليل ده يودي الى ان الاسره تبقى اكثر
ثباتا واكثر دكتور دكتور احمد دكتور عادل
طرح نقطه مهمه اذا ترد عليه سمعتها
اولا احنا يعني كما قلت لا نلغي الايه ولا
الحديث ثم ان في قاعده فقهيه دفع المفاسد
مقدم على جلب المصالح يعني هل نجعل الشك
والظن يدخل في الاسر
لامور لا يعني لا ياباها الدين ويباها
العرف
ودفع المفاسر كما قلت مقدم على جلب
المصالح يعني كل الاسر الان تذهب الى
المعامل
ليطمئن الزوج على ان الاولاد منه هذا شر
هذا شر يؤدي الى خلخله في المجتمع احنا عم
نحكي يعني اذا بتسمح لي دكتور دكتور احمد
يعني في في اغلب القصص اللي سمعناها في
مصر التي تتعلق بتحليل الدي ان ايه كان
الموضوع بانه كان في هناك زواج يمكن عرفي
او او بالسر وصار في انجاب وفي اولاد
والاب يتنصل من عبوتهم طيب يعني تحليل
الدي ان ايه في مثل هذه الحاله اذا كان
هناك نص قانوني واللي هو مش موجود في مصر
يجبر الاب على اجراء هذا التحليل طب اليس
ذلك بالعكس شيء ايجابي وشيء يساهم في
تماسك الاسره وخلق اسره جديده بدل ما نترك
الام لوحدها هي التي تربي الولد والولد
بدون نسب مثبت
حتى لو كان والشروط في عقد الزواج نعم
ولكن في بعض الزوج لا نلتزم
الان احنا الاثار المترتبه على عقد الزواج
الصحيح
المستوفر اركان والشروط اثبات النسب اما
ان تاتي علاقات معينه او ممارسات معينه عن
الاطار الشرعي الصحيح للزواج
انتم تريدون تطويع الشريعه لاهواء لا لا
لا لا دكتور دكتور احمد اذا سمحت لي احنا
قاعد نتكلم بحاله معينه ارجوك لا تسقط
علينا شيء يعني فبالتالي احنا لما نقول
اذا صار الشيء الحديث لكم
عفوا يعني انت تقول لا نفتح الشكوك ولا
الظنون انا لا اتوجه اليكم لكن انا اقول
للمجتمع ولمن يعنيه الامر هذه بناء الاسر
المسلمه بناء مستقر لا نفتح لها ابواب
الشكوك من اما علاقات خارج اطار الزواج
اما علاقات خارج اطار الزواج
السؤال كما نقول اذا تكرمت احنا نقول اذا
كان احد الطرفين اذا تكرمت بس دكتور احمد
يطول لي بالك يعني حتى يستفيد المشاهد اذا
تكرمت اليوم نقول اذا الزوج شك بهذا الامر
هل يذهب هل يحق له هل من المفترض ان يطالب
هو هي علاقه هناك من هو ضعيف نفس هل نفس
البشريه كما يقال اماره بالسوء
هذا الامر قلت لك قد يكون قرينه لكن ليس
دليلا شرعيا ولا نشجع الناس على مثل هذه
الامور لان اليقين يقدم على الشك هذه
قاعده فقهيه وهذا هو ديننا وهذا هو
اسلامنا الزواج في اطاره الصحيح يثبت
النسب اما علاقات اخرى او يفتح الباب للشك
والظن والوهم وهذا يؤدي الى اهتزاز الاسر
وفقدان الثقه هذا لا يليق بالاسر المسلمه
يعني هو دكتور الهدف في النهايه سواء كان
من نصوص الشرعيه والقواعد الشرعيه او حتى
من النصوص القانونيه هو صلاح المجتمع على
كل حال اشكرك جزيل الشكر بدايه اشكر دكتور
عادل عاشور استاذ الوراثه الكلينيكيه
بالمركز القومي للبحوث وايضا اشكرك دكتور
احمد كريمه استاذه الشريعه الاسلاميه
بجامعه الازهر
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات